the white house that was supposedly
going to be all about transparency and
openness and keeping the American people
informed and part of the communication
about what they're doing has now gone
six months without holding a traditional
press briefing there's been a different
press secretary there is a different
press secretary in place now than six
months ago but it has been six full
months and there is no sign that the
White House is going to resume these
press briefings and part of the problem
is probably that the current press
secretary wouldn't be able to handle
press briefings her name is Stephanie
Grisham she replaced of course Sarah
Huckabee Sanders when Sanders left and
recently Stephanie Grisham put out a
statement answering questions about why
why are there no press briefings and
this is genius in in the sense that it
is evil disinformation genius they are
indirectly referring to Twitter to
excuse not having press briefings check
this out and look at the language that's
used quote this is White House press
secretary Stephanie Grisham to ABC News
President Trump communicates directly
with the American people more than any
president in history
the fact that the White House press
corps can no longer grandstand on TV is
of no concern to us she's essentially
saying Trump speaks directly to the
American people she means Twitter right
and thus we don't even really need press
briefings where of course reporters get
to asks ask questions and sometimes call
lies out instead Trump goes on Twitter
where it is one-way communication with
Trump blocking detractors on Twitter
people he doesn't like and no
opportunity for serious follow-ups from
actual journalists that is what they are
using to defend not having a press
briefing in six months despite claiming
both before and during the presidency
that they are the most open and
transparent administration in history
which of course only an idiot or someone
can consistently and persistently
misinformed would ever fall for and
what's happening is that Grisham really
can't handle what it is that would
happen during a press briefing aside
from not even doing the brief
she also has done barely any interviews
I'm aware of only one that she did with
that right-wing TV station ownership
group Sinclair Broadcast Group and
specifically the interviewer was that
right-wing commentator Eric Bolling I
don't even get what she's doing to earn
her salary she's not talking to the
press in press briefings she's barely
doing interviews I don't even really
understand the point and of course part
of the explanation that the press
briefings are merely something that
allowed the press corps which they've
characterized as just liberal which is
of course not true that it's merely a
venue for the press corps to grandstand
this is another authoritarian tendency
it's part of the press is bad letting
the press ask questions is bad instead
we are going to do one-way communication
which is reminiscent of the endless
speeches of the despotic dictators the
world over ranging from you know we
don't have to mention the German guy but
we can just go more recently Castro
would just do one-way communication the
Chavez's erro duo loves one-way
communication with no opportunity for
challenging and pushing back against
what's being said this is a hallmark of
those with authoritarian tendencies and
this is actually particularly of concern
because it actually might set a new
standard or a new expectation even for
future presidents there would be I'm
hoping future presidents that don't have
the anti media authoritarian tendencies
of Donald Trump that don't share his
disdain for the press but if we go not
six months but another year and a half
up until the next inauguration of Trump
loses that would be two years of no
press briefings or almost no press
briefings it may start to seem like the
norm even for future presidents I hope
that that's not the case but that is a
concern the most transparent
administration in history right all they
do is lie and obfuscate and then
canceled a few opportunities that even
exist to ask questions about those lies
and obfuscation and they defend it with
well Trump's tweeting he's communicating
directly with the American people so
it's all fine
this is the authoritarian slide that
we've been talking about for years at
this point let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show and I
hope you'll join me tonight
on twitch for a live stream
twitch.tv/eds VIN Charo watches giving
our audience 15% off everything they
offer these guys are awesome they craft
really stylish top-quality watches for
both men and women but they sell them at
a fair price unlike a lot of their
competitors VIN Charo assembles their
watches in small batches which enables
them to meticulously ensure the quality
of every watch I personally wear of inch
arrow watch I don't like the idea of
spending thousands of dollars on a watch
when I can get a really excellent watch
for a hundred and fifty two hundred
bucks that's what I think is great about
VIN chair oh you get a watch made from
top-notch materials they look like
watches that you'd spend a ton of money
on and they're built like high-end
watches designed mechanically with
longevity in mind but you don't have to
spend an arm and a leg their entire goal
is to make watches of superior quality
available to the average person I just
got a new one called the Kairos I got
the white and silver version it looks
great I've gotten a ton of compliments
they have a huge variety of style so it
was easy to find one that fits my tastes
there are a bunch of other companies out
there selling watches at similar prices
but a lot of them look very cookie
cutter and just don't offer the same
level of craftsmanship as what you get
from bench arrow you're not going to
find a better maid watch at this grade
of a price they've got a watch for any
type of look you're trying to go for
formal more casual the straps and colors
are interchangeable so you can customize
your watch to your own preference and
you can get 15% off everything in their
store when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch and use the code Pakman at
checkout